the city of kenosha in wisconsin has
declared a curfew until the morning over
unrest in the city triggered
by the shooting of a black man a word of
warning you might find the following
footage disturbing angry crowds gathered
over a video appearing to show police
shooting
a black man in the back several times
jacob blake is in a
serious condition in hospital the police
department has so far
offered little information as to what
led to the shooting
protesters have clashed with police in
one instance a demonstrator even threw a
brick at an officer
who collapsed to the ground protesters
have also allegedly broken into the
local courthouse
and looting has been reported in the
area
well there have been also huge
demonstrations over the fatal shooting
of a black man in the u.s state of
louisiana footage of the
moments leading up to the 31 year old
trafford
uh 31 year old traitor pellini's death
have gone viral a word of warning too
you might find this
video disturbing also
[Applause]
on friday according to authorities
pellerin was armed with a knife and
tried to enter a convenience store
officers tasered him but said it was
ineffective so shot
11 rounds killing the man people
immediately flooded
onto the streets in protest
hundreds marched to the lafayette police
station demanding justice the incidents
over the weekend following months of
rallies against
alleged racial injustice journalist
daniel azari
shared his thoughts on the latest
developments
they've achieved they've certainly
brought the broad uh dramatized the
problem
uh they've uh they've impressed of the
much of the population there really is a
serious problem
uh but the american political structure
is as unresponsive as ever the chasm
between
uh rich and poor uh is is enormous and
is getting worse by the uh by the year
uh american political institutions by
certain measures are more racist now
than they were
60 years ago for example so the american
government
is actually in some ways more distant
now from the needs of ordinary
uh working-class people than it was 60
years ago
wealth polarization is shooting through
the roof and political instability is
growing
you